good morning youtubers my name is John
Holmes and I'm responsible for
coordinating disaster relief in the
world dealing with the poorest and those
suffering the most in the world my plea
to people in countries or companies or
England individual in particular those
who are here at Devils at the moment is
when they're talking about the financial
crisis or a big political crisis of the
world to give a bit more thought to the
effect on the ground in the real world
particularly on the poorest in the world
only a small proportion of the resources
that go into financial issues whether
they're being lost or or one of the many
billions we're talking about any small
portion of those resources given to
those poorest in the world would make a
difference only small proportion of
thoughts going to the effect on those
people not just the poorest but also in
developing countries in general could
make a huge difference so let's make a
bit more of a connection between those
debates and the realities on the ground
and we have a mechanism to do that for
example through the centre the load is a
response funder to the UN fund to help
disaster leave any contributions are
very welcome and gratefully received
thank you very much